Could Lucifer lose his immortality?
Will Ella uncover the devil's secret?
And who will end up ruler of Hell by the end
of the series?
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, I'm Jan and in
this video we're investigating 15 incredible
yet possible theories and predictions that
could change everything for the final two
seasons of Lucifer.
We'll be talking spoilers, so take care if
you're not caught up.
"This is gonna be good."
"Yeah, I'll have some of that."
A big moment in the first part of Season 5
comes when Lucifer regains his invulnerability
around Chloe.
Dan shoots the Devil with Chloe nearby, but
Lucifer emerges unscathed and rather pleased
with the outcome, even offering himself up
as a "Devil Shield" to the Detective.
But there was an important moment earlier
in Season 5 that suggests this development
could go into reverse, with Lucifer choosing
to forsake his invulnerability entirely to
become a mortal being.
In the noir episode, Lilith gives up her immortality
breathing into her ring that she gives Lucifer,
and explains an insight she's gleaned from
her thousands of years living among humans:
"They all think they want to live forever.
But they already have something so much more
precious.
It's knowing there's an end.
That's what makes the rest of it count.
That's what connects them to one another."
Likewise in season 3 we heard Cain, aka Marcus
Pierce, compare immortality to hell:
"I've walked this Earth for thousands of years.
I have seen everything, I have done everything."
It's almost like you're in..."
"Hell?
Yeah!"
Now that Lucifer and Chloe are a couple, what
could be worse for Lucifer than watching Chloe
eventually die and then continuing to live
for an eternity without her.
Back in 1946 when Lilith asked Lucifer if
he'd ever made an emotional connection with
a human, Luci scoffed at the notion.
"Ha!
It would take a literal miracle for me to
want something like that,
and I'm fairly certain my father's not handing
those out anymore."
But of course that did happen, so could Lucifer
decide to follow Lilith's example and give
up his own immortality, so that he and Chloe
can grow old together?
Or, alternatively, could Chloe become immortal
from the ring?
But then, what about Trixie?
Another outcome that could solve all that
is Lucifer being forgiven for his rebellion
and being able to return to the Silver City
when he wishes,
so that when Chloe eventually dies, they can
be together there as well.
In Season 5, while Luci returns to earth to
deal with Michael, Amenadiel takes his place
in Hell to keep the demons in check.
But to Lucifer's surprise, in the fifth episode,
he discovers Amenadiel's back with Linda,
and when Luci demands to know why he's left
Hell unguarded, Amenadiel explains:
"There I was...
wandering the corridors of Hell, when...
I heard a voice.
A voice that I never expected to hear in Hell."
According to Amenadiel, that voice was God
who told him that Hell no longer needed a
warden.
When I first saw this scene, it struck me
as odd, given that having a proper ruler watching
over the Underworld was such an important
plot point for Season 4.
And given that Amenadiel says he thought that
it was strange to hear God's voice in Hell,
I wonder whether Michael sneaked into Hell
and impersonated God's voice to fool Amenadiel
into leaving the Underworld without a ruler
again.
This could be yet another trick Michael has
pulled to make Luci look bad in front of their
father.
We know Michael can easily switch accents
and we already saw him performing this trick
on Dan when he called his phone pretending
to be Lucifer so that Dan would see Luci's
devil face.
Now that Dan's discovered Lucifer's true identity,
out of the main cast only Ella is still unware
that Luci is literally the devil.
However, I expect that will change when she
finally finds out by the end of Season 5.
And given Ella's religious beliefs, I think
this moment could be an even bigger shock
for her than it was for Chloe or Dan or Linda.
Ella says she grew up among criminals and
dirt bags, but that when she turned to God,
it set her on a better path.
So her reaction when she finds out she's been
living alongside the Devil as his friend in
LA will be very interesting.
Of course, this isn't the first time Ella's
unwittingly befriended a celestial, as her
ghost friend Ray-Ray was actually Luci's angel
sister Azrael.
Ella also has this dark side to her which
the show played up a lot more in Season 5
with her attraction to what she calls "bad
guys".
And then there was Pete, the seemingly nice
guy secret serial killer, who also said he
saw darkness in Ella.
And there was a very interesting moment in
the ¡Diablo! episode when Ella finds a prop
weapon
"supposed to be the only blade that can kill
the Devil"
and then proceeds to attack Lucifer with the
rubber knife.
"Hi-ya!
"Sorry, that seemed a lot funnier in my head."
"I'm sure."
Now, obviously the moment is played for laughs
here, but it could also be a little bit of
foreshadowing for Ella trying to attack the
Devil when she discovers him on Earth?
By the end of the series, I expect we will
find someone in charge of Hell who isn't Lucifer,
as I think God will at some point recognise
that he's done enough to serve out his punishment.
The most likely candidate at this point is
Michael, because once his dastardly schemes
against Lucifer are revealed to God,
he would surely get banished from Heaven,
and perhaps sent to the Underworld to rule
in Lucifer's place.
A possible, though less obvious, option for
new ruler of Hell would be Maze.
She was already keen to go back to Hell in
Season 1, but Lucifer insisted they stay in
LA and so she decided to find a purpose for
herself as a bounty hunter.
And at the start of season 5, Maze is mad
at Luci for going down to Hell without her.
The technical problem with Maze taking over
down under is that she's a demon, so theoretically
it would break this rule:
"Hell was built so that no demon could take
control of the throne.
Only a celestial could rule."
But given everything that happens in the show,
it's not impossible for this rule to be broken
if the writers wanted to make it work.
Something that could play into this is Maze
discovering that she isn't an ordinary demon
and does actually have a soul.
In fact, there was a hint to this in the "Mr
and Mrs Mazikeen Smith" episode of Season
3:
"When you kill, you lose a piece of your soul.
I get the feeling you understand that."
"Sorry.
No soul here."
"That's not what I see."
My other theory is that Maze will resolve
her existential angst via the ring her mother
Lilith gave Lucifer, and I go into detail
about that in my Ending Explained video.
Maze is such a fan favourite that I expect
she'll eventually find her soulmate by the
end of the series.
[At the moment] Eve seems like the best option
for Maze as they already formed a connection
in Season 4,
and if Maze is also in charge of Hell, then
I can definitely see Eve joining her there
as she enjoyed helping Luci punish sinners
when she was with him on Earth,
and then Kinley also suggested Eve could be
Queen of Hell with Lucifer, so why not with
Maze instead?
A character who might not make it out of the
series alive is Dan, though he could still
get a happy ending of sorts reuniting with
Charlotte in Heaven.
In the first episode of Season 5, we see that
despite his attempts to be positive, Dan is
still struggling to get over Charlotte's death
from Season 3.
I think he will get a special moment to shine
before the end of the series,
perhaps playing a crucial part in defeating
Michael as Lucifer saw an unusual strength
in Dan when he was wielding the powerful divine
weapon Azrael's Blade in Season 2:
"You're fighting the blade, which indicates
a strength I didn't know you had."
If Michael was able to send Amenadiel into
a fear spiral that made his time manipulation
powers go crazy,
could it be possible that Michael's fear mojo
was also to blame for that mysterious moment
in Season 4 when Lucifer's mojo powers went
haywire?
At the time, Lucifer's self-hatred and fear
that Chloe couldn't accept him for who he
truly was, meant he began transforming physically
into his full devil form,
but a side effect was that everyone in Lux
began to tell him what they desired, even
though he wasn't asking them.
Michael seems to like lurking in the shadows,
hidden from view, and in Season 5, there was
that moment where he vanishes into the crowd
at Lux.
Indeed Lucifer also commented that Michael
enjoys hiding himself away.
"If past is prologue, he's probably hidden
himself off somewhere to laugh about the mess
he's made..."
So, perhaps Michael has been around longer
than we know, causing havoc and triggering
events like Lucifer's mojo going wrong in
Season 4.
After all, he did tell Lucifer that he's basically
been manipulating him since the dawn of time.
Something which is still a mystery about Michael
is the reason for his slopey shoulder, as
Lucifer calls it.
I expect the backstory to this will be revealed
in the second part of Season 5, and it may
be an injury he suffered during Luci's rebellion
against God.
If Lucifer does have anything to do with it,
then of course it will be yet another of Michael's
grievances towards his brother.
The moment many Deckerstar fans waited five
seasons for finally happened when Lucifer
and Chloe did the deed and discovered that
Hell didn't freeze over.
But what are the chances that Chloe could
now be pregnant with Lucifer's child?
It already happened to Amenadiel and Linda
on the show and Lucifer even joked about it
when Chloe found herself naked in Lucifer's
bed in the first season:
"I'm pretty sure we made Rosemary's baby."
I don't think this will be a main plot point
as it could feel like too much of a repeat
of Charlie's storyline, and it's not something
I'm keen to see myself;
however, there are fans who would like this,
so it could be something that happens at the
very end of the series as a kind of epilogue,
if Lucifer and Chloe settle down together.
Speaking of which, it's entirely possible
we'll see the devilish couple tie the knot
before the show's over.
The "¡Diablo!" episode is packed with many
comical meta moments as Lucifer and Chloe
investigate a murder on a TV show inspired
by their own partnership.
During the case, Lucifer chances upon a script
for an unaired episode called "Diablo in Space".
And when he and Dan act out the script, they
read out the line "A devil in the heavens"
which makes me wonder if we can look forward
to a Lucifer episode that's actually set in
Heaven.
And I go into lots more detail about that
hilarious episode, including all the little
easter eggs and references, in my Season 5
Things You Missed video.
Tap the card here or follow the link in the
video description.
Perhaps the upcoming musical episode titled
"Bloody Celestial Karaoke Jam" will end up
taking place in Heaven, where we'll get to
meet another of Lucifer's siblings Castiel.
When Remy arrived on Earth in Season 4, Amenadiel
made reference to Castiel's love of song,
so it feels like this will be the appropriate
episode to introduce the character.
"So, what brings you to Earth?
you need a break from Castiel singing?"
And wouldn't it also be great if we got to
see Azrael again especially as Charlyne Yi
was just fantastic in that role in season
3.
The ending of Season 5 Part 1 seemingly reveals
that Charlie isn't a half-angel as we'd assumed
because he got sick with a fever and a cold.
However, I think there's something else going
on here which caused Charlie's illness.
The clue is in the episode just before when
Amenadiel is talking to Linda about how content
he is being a father and looking after Charlie.
Linda agrees, but then tells him to enjoy
the moment while it lasts and adds that if
they do a good job as parents, Charlie will
need them less and less every day.
Amenadiel seems somewhat perturbed by this
realisation and given we know that Michael
was trying to trigger his fears, could Amenadiel
have subconsciously accidentally made Charlie
ill?
Michael's fear mojo was powerful enough to
cause Amenadiel's time control powers to spiral
out of control, so what else could they have
affected?
My alternate theory on the cause of Charlie's
illness is that it's related to Amenadiel's
misdiagnosis of Chlamydia by a doctor in Season
3, and I explain all that in my Season 5 Part
1 Ending video.
So, what do you think about these theories
for the show's final two seasons?
And do you have any theories of your own on
how the series will end?
Leave your thoughts in the comments below.
Tap left to watch my next Lucifer video and
Season 5 playlist.
Or tap right for another video you're sure
to like.
And if you enjoyed this, a thumbs-up and a
share are hugely appreciated.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!